Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Here's a really cool computer animation problem,
you'll love this one: we take a digital character,
specify an initial pose and a target objective
- for instance, a position somewhere in space.
And the algorithm has to come up with a series
of smooth movements and contact interactions
to obtain this goal.
But these movements have to be physically
meaningful, such as that self-intersection
and non-natural contortions have to be avoided
throughout this process.
Keep an eye out for the white cross to see
where the target positions are.
Now, for starters, it's cool to see that humanoids
are handled quite well, but here comes the
super fun part: the mathematical formulation
of this optimization problem does not depend
on the body type at all, therefore, both humanoids
and almost arbitrarily crazy, non-humanoid
creatures are also supported.
If we make this problem a bit more interesting,
and make changes to the terrain to torment
these creatures, we'll notice that they come
up with sensible movements to overcome these
challenges.
These results are absolutely amazing.
And this includes obtaining highly non-trivial
target poses, such as handstands.
The goal does not necessarily have to be a
position, but it can be an orientation or
a given pose as well.
We can even add multiple characters to the
environment and ask them to join forces to
accomplish a task together.
And here you can see that both characters
take into consideration the actions of the
other one and not only compensate accordingly,
but they make sure that this happens in a
way that brings them closer to their objective.
It is truly incredible to see how these digital
characters can learn such complex animations
in a matter of minutes.
A true testament to the power of mathematical
optimization algorithms.
If you wish to hear more about how optimization
works, we've had a previous episode on this
topic, make sure to check it out, it includes
a rigorous mathematical study on how to make
the perfect vegetable stew.
The link is available in the video description.
And, if you feel a bit addicted to Two Minute
Papers, please note that these episodes are
available in early access through Patreon,
click on the icon with the "p" at the ending
screen if you're interested.
It also helps us a great deal in improving
the quality of the series.
We try to be as transparent as possible, and
every now and then we write a technical memo
to summarize the recent improvements we were
able to make, and this is all thanks to you.
If you're interested, I've put a link to the
latest post in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!